hi Jordan how are you there are good
days how are you thanks for taking my
call sure what's up so we have kind of a
situation here my wife and I recently
got married this last November and she
has about two hundred fifty thousand
dollars in student loans from a ph.d
program which she is finishing up
graduating next year they're in
deferment right now and then we have
about fourteen thousand and credit card
debt on top of that and I'm just trying
to figure out what the best way to
approach this is I sure hope she's
planning to make some money me too she
wants to establish a private practice
eventually down the road and then go
into college like be a professor
somewhere a PhD in one psychology so
she's a licensed professional counselor
she works in a psych hospital right now
Wow oh okay what do you make I make
fifty five she makes the route the same
so we pull in 110 together good lord
all right well what we've got to do is
we have to start working on there has to
be some mathematical payoff for this PhD
that beats fifty five thousand maybe a
hundred and fifty five thousand and that
that's a professorship and private
practice combined or something like that
but in in pursuit of her PhD she has
made a financial disaster and the only
way to solve that is income so he does
have a ten year forgiveness program I
know other people have mentioned that in
the past thing he said you know why wait
ten years when you can pay it off now
but once you make ten payments for ten
years I'm sorry payments for ten years
no no able it'll forgive the rest under
that
and I know how it works but I mean why
would you want to be in debt for ten
years I mean I agree I mean I totally
agree we do have a house that's worth
165 roughly and we only owe a hundred on
it so what I was thinking is like maybe
try to sell it and rent and use that 65
and equity and least knock out a quarter
of it yeah that that would be my last
resort my first choice is for her to do
something that maybe is not necessarily
what her first choice is hopefully it's
her first choice but but but do the
thing that she can do with the phd that
makes her the most possible money yep
and pay a price for a little while to
clean this mess up if it's if the price
is discomfort or it's not self
actualization will so be it because
you've got a tremendous hole and the
only way you know what I always look at
is just the shovel to hole ratio Jordan
and the shovel is your income your
household incomes 110 I need it to be
200 and to make this work and because
the hole is 250 and so you know if you
had a $200,000 income you can pay this
off in 3 or 4 years and you'll be done
and but that but that may be doing
something she doesn't necessarily deem
as wonderful but you also the only other
option is something that's not wonderful
and that's being $250,000 in debt and so
I do not know what a professorship pays
in that setting but my guess would be
north of a hundred and what has she got
to do to get to lend that and you can
simultaneously in most cases do private
practice and I would do anything they do
to create money for a short period of
time the more money you create in the
shortest possible period of time the
faster you're free and so the whole idea
here is to be free and then you go do
whatever you want to do with this
wonderful degree and so forth but not
much thought was put into the cost of
the degree going in now so we're going
to have to put a whole lot of thought
into the income produced by the degree
to clean the mess up